george carlin is still comedy's greatest
messenger but you'll be surprised to see
just how much his message has changed
over the years impossible to pick up a
newspaper these days without reading
something about a protest or a march or
a demonstration this group is protesting
another group's march and demonstrating
against their bonfire in their rally the
pickets are against the pickets they're
picketing the pickets now there's even
one group that next week is having a
parade to protest the fact that they
can't get a parade permit now that's
kind of strange the early george was
refined and playful but the older george
[ __ ] is everywhere
[ __ ] is rampant
parents are full of [ __ ] teachers are
full of [ __ ] clergymen are full of [ __ ]
law enforcement people are full of [ __ ]
the entire country is completely full of
[ __ ]
in fact this country was founded by a
group of slave owners who told us that
all men are created equal
that is what's known
as being stunningly
stunningly full of [ __ ]